200 partes civiles 14 acusados es sin
duda un juicio histórico que por lo
mismo está siendo grabado para quedar en
los archivos de la historia francesa es
el decimosegundo en serlo y el primero
de tipo terrorista y este primer día de
proceso de los atentados de enero del
2015 estuvo dedicado justamente a
revisar esa amplia investigación sobre
estos terribles ataques que dejaron 17
muertos y decenas de heridos
en parís y justamente en el centro
estuvieron las víctimas los familiares y
los sobrevivientes vimos por ejemplo a
la madre de stefan jabón y ella el
fallecido director de saliendo salir
llorando de la sala cuando el juez se
equivocaba el mencionar el nombre de su
hijo y ser atendida por uno de los
voluntarios de la asociación de ayuda a
las víctimas de terrorismo que van a
estar aquí los 49 días que dure este
proceso vimos también a reese el actual
director de saliendo tomarse la cabeza
al escuchar el relato de ese terrible 7
de enero del año 2015 conversamos
justamente con el fundador de la
asociación para víctimas del terrorismo
él nos dijo que éste
pese a que los culpables están muertos
es muy importante primero porque las
familias y los sobrevivientes quieren
saber realmente cómo pasaron los hechos
en segundo lugar porque necesitan
liberar su palabra ahora quizás con más
serenidad y en tercer lugar porque
quieren demostrar que los que hicieron
estos ataques no triunfaron infundiendo
el odio y el miedo en la sociedad